mesdames et messieurs bonjour aussi les
dernières images reçues de salut les
dernières images des trois cosmonautes
soviétiques qui vous savez sont morts à
l'issue de l'expérience 29 juin 1971
georges dobrowolski vladimir volkoff et
victor pas de cf meurt à bord du soyouz
il rentrait d'une mission menée sur la
station orbitale sa lutte 1
c'est le choc car jusqu alors aucun
homme n'était mort dans l'espace c'est
fini une dernière image de sayoud filmé
par soyeuse 11
pourtant tout avait bien commencé les
trois cosmonautes soviétiques s'était
envolé vers la station orbitale le 6
juin 1971 à 200 km d'altitude
il avait réalisé toute une série
d'expériences scientifiques
il avait même battu le record de vie en
orbite de 24 jours avant de regagner eux
mêmes le vaisseau et les examine le
système d'arrimage saliou ça use
c'est peut-être ce système qui les a
trahis il quitte la station à bord de
soyouz 11
alors que le vol de retour semble se
passer normalement
la base de baïkonour au kazakhstan perd
le contact avec l'équipage
lorsque la capsule a atterri le 29 juin
1971 à 23h17 gmt
les trois hommes sont retrouvés morts en
fait on ne sait pas très bien à quel
moment les trois hommes sont morts à
8h30 hier soir il avait dit tout va bien
on alors que les autorités soviétiques
reste silencieuse le monde entier
s'interroge sur l'origine de l'accident
les choses ont dû se passer très
rapidement parce comme il ya une
pression atmosphérique normale à
l'intérieur de la cabine le vide à
l'extérieur la moindre pluie provoque un
appel d'air extrêmement rapide et les
hommes ont dû en un temps très court
se retrouver complètement un soutier
mourir par l'absence de protection des
cosmonautes soviétiques les pointer du
doigt les côtes sont remontés à bord en
manche de chemise en survêtement et sans
combinaison pressurisée
une lacune dictée par l'agencement du
soyouz lui même parce que le soyouz et
continue de sectes ou les tensions ne
permet pas malheureusement en 1972 l'
enquête officielle dévoilera que ce sont
des valves utilisés pour gérer la
pression qui ont provoqué la
dépressurisation
juste après la séparation du module
orbital de soyouz l'air s'est échappé en
une trentaine de secondes l'équipage est
mort asphyxié
[Musique]